[Aplausos]
el turismo resucita por semana santa y
es que hasta nueva zelanda reabrió sus
fronteras a los australianos un año
después
más de dos años de pandemia dieron un
respiro medioambiental algunos de los
emblemas turísticos del mundo como la
isla difícil de tailandia conocida por
la película la playa con leonardo
dicaprio tres años después ha abierto
tras cerrar por el deterioro
medioambiental
otros países ya habían abierto sus
puertas con anterioridad sin embargo es
en esta pascua cuando han vuelto a
contar con altos niveles de ocupación en
el caribe de méxico se esperan ingresos
un 67 por ciento mayores que en 2021 ni
el sargazo ha evitado la llegada de
turistas noto algo muy diferente y algo
más como el mar tiene un color especial
una gran recuperación se ha sentido en
los países del sur de europa en portugal
esperan terminar con números de 2019 con
una ocupación hotelera del 80 por ciento
y
ya se ha sentido alguna mejora en la
parte hotelera y esperamos y confiamos
en que las próximas semanas y meses
regrese el turismo totalmente economía o
turismo totalmente cómodo
más al norte en reinounido notan la
falta de turistas rusos por la guerra y
de chinos por su cierre de fronteras
pero para esta experta hay buenas
expectativas hunwick podemos ver que la
gente está realmente interesada en
volver a viajar el 80 por ciento dicen
que quieren hacer un viaje este año
perspectivas que el sector espera que
culminen en un verano boreal histórico
para los países del hemisferio norte